puis dans la hotte de ce père noël en
vedette les jeux électroniques japonais
leurs ventes ont progressé de près de
200 % cette année ça touche tout le
monde les enfants comme les adultes
un reportage de catherine sabah et
habile djoudi pour noël les envahisseurs
ni pourront encore frappé avec 30% des
ventes des rayons jouets des plus grands
magasins les jeux vidéo laisse loin
derrière les trains électriques et les
ballons de foot et les premières atteint
par le nouveau péril jaune non pas 10
ans sur un pépin de villes défigurées
s'accumulent s'accumulent et et après on
l'a perdu j'emprunte passer des cases et
là on voit nekkaz qui vont arriver après
le plus petit le game boy et
transportable partout à partir de 600
francs dans la gamme supérieure il faut
compter 250 francs pour une cassette
jusqu'à 1000 francs pour des consoles
classiques les deux grandes marques qui
se disputent le marché ont compris que
le prix était l'élément déterminant pour
convaincre les parents par rapport aux
produits au premier productions sorties
ya une dizaine d'années les prix ont
beaucoup baissé
donc ce qui fait qu'ils sont devenus
abordables de lancement tout le monde
aujourd'hui quatre foyers sur cinq
serait équipé d'une console de jeux
vidéo et devant l'écran les enfants ou
leurs papas rivalisent d'assiduité
parfois jusqu'à trois ou quatre heures
d'affilée
on écoute chacun sa petite musique dans
son coin on communique pas avec l'au
delà on peut s'asseoir dans un coin
comme ça qu'à celles jouées pendant des
heures sans s'occuper du reste du monde
dommage et si demain matin vos enfants
découvrent ces nouveaux joujoux dans
leurs petits souliers vous aurez au
moins la certitude d'avoir la paix toute
la journée